>>> IN 2018, AMAZON IS SHOWING
CUSTOMERS A NEW WAY TO SHOP
WHERE YOU CAN JUST GRAB AND GO.
IT'S AMAZON --
>> GRAB WHAT I WANT AND LEAVE?
>> YEP.
>> WOW.
THAT'S SO EASY.
>> USE THE AMAZON GO APP TO
ENTER, THEN START SHOPPING.
>> THAT'S IT?
>> THAT'S IT.
NO LINES, NO CHECKOUT, NO
PROBLEM.
AT AN AMAZON GO STORE, YOU CAN
WALK IN, GRAB -- YOU CAN WALK
IN, GRAB WHAT YOU WANT, PUT IT
IN YOUR BAG, AND JUST GO.
>> OH, YOU WANT ME TO JUST TAKE
SOMETHING AND WALK OUT?
NAH, SON.
>> BUT -- IT'S SO CONVENIENT.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
NICE TRY.
>> WE KNOW SOME PEOPLE ARE
SKEPTICAL.
>> SOME PEOPLE?
>> WELL, HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
WE USE COMPUTER VISION.
>> UH-HUH?
>> DEEP LEARNING ALGORITHMS.
>> HM.
>> AND SENSOR FUSION.
>> OH, OKAY.
SO IT'S A TRAP.
SO WHERE DO YOU PAY?
>> THERE'S NO REGISTER.
IT ALL HAPPENS WITH OUR OF GRAB
AND GO TECHNOLOGY.
>> BUT WHERE DO YOU PAY?
>> YOU DON'T.
>> NO, I DO.
I ALWAYS PAY, OKAY?
WHO DO YOU THINK I AM?
>> IT'S SIMPLE.
TAKE WHAT YOU WANT.
PUT IT IN YOUR OWN BAG.
AND WALK OUT.
AND WE HAVE EVERYTHING YOU LOVE.
>> OH, HEY, THEY HAVE MY
FAVORITE BRAND OF KOMBUCHA.
>> OH, IT'S GREAT, YOU SHOULD
GRAB IT.
>> SURE.
CAN YOU GRAB IT?
>> ME?
NO, JUST GRAB IT.
>> YOU SHOULD PICK IT UP.
>> BABE, IT'S FINE.
>> PICK IT UP.
>> I'M LEARNING.
>> IF YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND, JUST
PUT IT BACK.
OUR TECHNOLOGY WILL UPDATE YOUR
VIRTUAL CART INSTANTLY.
>> OKAY, I AM -- PUTTING THE
SANDWICH BACK, YOU ALL!
I HAVE DECIDED TO GET A
DIFFERENT SANDWICH TODAY!
I GOT NO MORE SANDWICHES NOW!
>> SO GET YOUR PURCHASE AND GO.
>> GO AHEAD, LEAVE.
JUST WALK OUT.
>> HERE I GO.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT,
YOU'VE ALREADY PAID.
>> WELL, THEN -- IT'S A TIP.
IT'S A TIP!
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO TRICK ME
[ BEEPING ]
HERE WE GO, I TOLD YOU.
>> IT'S JUST NOTIFYING YOU OF
YOUR RECEIPTS.
>> IT WAS HIM!
>> AMAZON GO.
NO LINE, NO CHECKOUT.
NO, SERIOUSLY.
>> IT'S A DAMN TRAP.
[ APPLAUSE ]